i want to see if you can guess the most
common craving
in the entire world okay so i'm going to
describe it let's see if you can guess
it and of course the craving comes from
a combination of things of what it can
do to
the receptors in your taste buds and the
actual texture which is
very
creamy
it has a good amount of fat in it it has
very unique flavors and aromas
and it's sweet
and it can give you a lot of pleasure
when you consume this both in the
combination of texture flavor and
sweetness but what it can do for you
okay what it does to the brain
is it decreases
a compound in your brain called
adenosine okay adenosine is a
something that helps you sleep and so if
you're consuming this thing you're
actually blocking this compound and it's
making you more awake okay it also has
something called tyrosine which can also
increase this neurotransmitter dopamine
which can actually increase your
pleasure so this thing that most people
are addicted i'm sorry craving has
certain chemicals that affect the brain
cognitive function improvements okay so
you may feel that you have more clarity
with your thinking you may have more
concentration and more focus
and it also affects your mood so if you
have depression or anxiety can actually
pull you out of that
because it helps you with stress
it's also very common to help
stabilize emotions with women that go
through their menstrual cycle hint
it also has effects on your insulin okay
it can actually make insulin more
sensitive so if you have insulin
resistance
it can
improve that thus stabilizing your blood
sugars
it has in one ounce
64 milligrams of magnesium okay
now magnesium
relaxes you magnesium gives you energy
and magnesium is involved in like 300
different enzymes so it does a lot it
can also affect your body in other ways
like in one study i found it can reduce
coughing it can help your cardiovascular
system in that it can help reduce
blood pressure so if you guessed this
you are correct chocolate is hands down
the most common craving that people have
i am definitely not opposed to consuming
chocolate as long as you don't get the
regular chocolate with all the sugar you
need to get keto friendly
chocolate because
all that sugar is going to counter
the positive effects that chocolate can
have on your body and of course because
chocolate has certain stimulants you
wouldn't want to necessarily consume it
in the later part of the day at night
especially if you have sleeping problems
and you have a little too much it can
keep you up at night but the theobromine
which is a different chemical can
apparently and help you sleep but just
for the fact that it has caffeine you
got to be careful about that now dark
chocolate okay why does it have all
these health claims well i really think
it has to do with it has number one the
least amount of sugar and it has the
most concentrated
phytonutrients okay now these
phytonutrients are fascinating and they
are part of the factors that give
chocolate its flavoring and i think
you'd be quite surprised
to find out where these flavors really
come from they come from the microbes
okay because chocolate is fermented so
that means that it gets help from the
microbes so apparently it seems that all
these wonderful
things that we would love to eat with
all these flavors
comes back to these microbes the
fermentation process you have bread
right you have cheese
butter which is fermented you have wine
beer and of course chocolate all of
those are fermented so these microbes
are just fascinating because they give
certain foods
interesting flavors so they interact
with different things different fibers
and foods and they turn those into
various
aromatic chemicals that give flavor now
some important information with
chocolate
make sure it's keto friendly which means
get a chocolate that has an alternative
sweetener other than sugar don't even
eat chocolate if it has honey in it okay
or coconut sugar
you want something like xylitol or monk
fruit or stevia
or
erythritol or even allulose and you
really want to make sure that it doesn't
have any soluble corn fiber because this
is so badly processed and the studies
out on this are so scarce and most of
them are
from industry and so
we don't know of the effects that this
has on our gut microbiome
also make sure it doesn't have the
tapioca fiber which also
you know these new functional fibers
that are uh
being put in so many different keto
friendly so-called healthy foods which
the jury is still out on that and of
course no resistant maltodextrin it's in
the same family as all this as well as
no
dextrin now since we're on the topic of
cravings if you haven't seen my video on
sugar you should check that out i put it
right here